because after all it's only January of
2023 we are not paying of much attention
to 2024 polling we're looking at it sort
of every three weeks every four weeks I
can't quite remember the last time we
looked at it but it is not irrelevant
and particularly when we are asking the
question is Trump's campaign for the
primary nomination imploding before it
even gets going when we are not yet sure
that Joe Biden is running for
re-election because despite what he says
he has not actually announced that he is
running for re-election at this time or
filed to run for reelection there's a
lot of question marks and interesting
things going on the aftermath of the
2022 midterms Etc so let's look at where
the numbers are and this morning there
was a headline Trump leads Biden in
hypothetical 2024 matchup according to a
new poll that is indeed true Emerson
College has released a new poll which
finds that Trump is leading Biden
44-41 however you do have 14 percent of
respondents who are not in either Camp
yet 10 say well I would support someone
else four percent were simply undecided
but I think the takeaway given that
Emerson is a pretty good pollster and
we'll see how good in a moment is that
it is very much not a foregone
conclusion that Trump can't win or that
Trump is certain to win and it is very
much not a foregone conclusion that Joe
Biden would have an easy time getting
reelected or that Joe Biden would be
unable to get himself reelected neither
it is a very very unclear scenario now
if we want to zoom out a little bit and
say okay but David that's one poll from
Emerson what if we look a little more
broadly I love that idea so then we
would go to 538's aggregation of
different polls and there you will find
the Emerson poll I just mentioned the
Emerson poll that's an A minus rated
pollster in a Biden DeSantis matchup
it's essentially even it's Biden plus
one and in that Biden Trump match-up as
I just told you Emerson has it Trump
plus three but what about other
pollsters well let's look morning
consult which is a b-rated poster has a
poll that's one day newer in Biden
versus DeSantis they have DeSantis ahead
whereas in Biden versus Trump they have
Biden ahead by three points all right
what about a different poll well we have
one from a few days ago this is a Harris
poll Harris is a b-plus rated pollster
in that poll Biden DeSantis has DeSantis
up three and Biden Trump has Trump up
five and then lastly and this is the
last one because then we'll get kind of
to our bigger observations yougov which
is a B plus rated pollster
Biden Trump has Biden up four
um and in a slightly different
formulation they have Biden up six
that's
um
registered voters versus what is a I
forget what a is not actual likely
anyway
um and then in Biden DeSantis they have
it even so what's the real takeaway here
the real takeaway is not no one of these
polls is really going to tell us
everything that we need to know the
takeaway is anything quite literally
could happen in 2024. we are not even
really in the primary season Donald
Trump did something that's sort of out
of not out of character for him but it's
out of norms historically to announce so
early that he is running he is scheduled
to start
um campaign events soon although I don't
know that they're going to be massive
rallies in fact he does have an event in
South Carolina this weekend our
correspondent Luke Beasley will be there
and we will have clips of interviews
with South Carolinian Trump supporters
for you on an upcoming program
um the takeaway is we don't have any
idea what could happen and so any
statements that sound like foregone
conclusions of the sort of Biden doesn't
have to worry or Biden has no chance
Trump's got this in the bag or Trump has
no chance none of those statements are
accurate at this point in time now what
about the Republican primary this is a
very interesting question because there
is a candidate who has not even
announced that he is running Ron
DeSantis who had some polling that
looked pretty good
more recently it doesn't look quite so
good for Ron DeSantis in a recent
morning consult poll Trump is leading
DeSantis by 19 in the primary in a
recent Emerson poll Trump is leading
descent despite 26. in a recent b-rated
big Village poll Trump is leading
DeSantis by 23 and in a recent Harris
poll Trump is leading DeSantis
um wait Trump Tim Scott Trump plus 50.
oh this is oh this is against other
people okay Trump is leading DeSantis by
10 in a Harris poll so even though there
was a period about a month ago or so
where Ron DeSantis was actually leading
Trump in a bunch of different polls
despite the fact that Trump has
announced and DeSantis has not which was
quite stunning it does not seem to be
the most common scenario right now
that's where we are Anything could
happen anything could change but we will
follow it probably like roughly every
three or four weeks one of of our
sponsors is curiositystream the best
place to find and watch documentaries on
politics history science technology
nature you name it they have it
curiosity stream has a deeper collection
of documentaries than any other
streaming service they add new titles
every week including exclusive
award-winning films and shows you can't
watch anywhere else I just watched
ancient engineering
fascinating insights into how stuff was
built before modern technology and the
Industrial Revolution you can watch
curiosity stream on all of your devices
phone desktop game console Smart TV I'm
always finding great documentaries on
curiosity stream that I can't find on
any other platforms it's really the only
place to go for documentaries and they
have a special deal for my audience you
can get curiosity stream for 25 off just
go to curiositystream.com Pacman and use
the code Pacman the link is down below